تحبس نيويورك انفاسها انتظارا ليوم
الثلاثاء ففي ذلك اليوم يتعين على الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامبا المثول
امام محكمه مانهاتن ومواجهه تهم على راسها
شراء صمت ممثله اباحيه عام 2016 مقابل 130
الف دولار
وفيما الاستنفار على اشده امنيا واعلاميا
نقلت وكاله سوشيت براس عن مصادر مطلعه
قولها ان ترامب يواجه تهمه جنائيه واحده
على الاقل في لائحه الاتهام التي اقرتها
هيئه محلفين في منهاتا واوضحت الوكاله ان
الرئيس السابق يواجه التهم المتعدده اخرى
بتزوير سجلات تجاريه سيكشف عنها ايضا يوم
الثلاثاء ورجح تلك المصادر ان يتم احتجاز
ترامب لكن حمله الرئيس السابق بدات واثقه
من اخلاء سبيله فقد اكدت في بيان ان ترامب
سيلقي خطابا علنيا من ولايه فلوريدا يوم
الثلاثاء المقبل بعد عودته من نيويورك
اكثر من ذلك اعلنت الحمله عن زياده هائله
في التبرعات الماليه بعد قرار الاتهام
محامي ترامب اعتبر ان موكله يواجه قضيه
اضطهاد سياسي ومع ذلك فهو يتطلع الى تبرئه
الرئيس السابق باسرع وقت ممكن
يستعد لهذه المعركه ومن الواضح انها قضيه
اضطهاد سياسي واعتقد ان الناس سواء
المعارضون له او المؤيدون يعتقدون انها
اساءه كامله لاستخدام السلطه ترامب رجل
قوي وسيكون مستعدا لهذه المعركه كما قلت
ونحن ايضا كفريق محامين جاهزون لها ونتطلع
للمضي قدما باسرع ما يمكن لتبرئته ترامب
المقيم في فلوريدا يتوقع ان يمثل امام
المحكمه طواعيه ومن ثم تتلى عليه التهم
وتؤخذ بصماته وصوره له مثل ما هي
الاجراءات المتبعه ضد اي متهم انما فقط لن
توضع الاغلال في يديه وستكون تلك التدابير
سابقه اذ لم يخضع لها اي رئيس امريكي في
الماضي